foreign
the temptation to keep playing even
though the rewards are done isn't that
the definition of addiction
and so
yes continuing a behavior even though
it's not rewarding you anymore
so to me that's what making money is
it's a game that I've decided to stop
playing because I got enough
but this could apply to anything
somebody who
wanted to be a successful
musician oh there's a great Gautier
Gautier I think that's how they
pronounce it you didn't have to cut me
out you know now you're just somebody
that I used to know that guy one hit
wonder
Gautier from Australia
that was his stage name and he did a
beautiful thing as he has retired that
stage name he's like there did it I had
a massive number one hit I don't want to
keep singing that song for the rest of
my life there is no more Gautier so now
he's just back to his legal name and
he's the drummer and singer in a band
called the basics
and he retired Gotye he stepped away
Jacinda ardern the most recent prime
minister of New Zealand after six years
felt that she had had enough
and she quit instead of going through
the process of running for re-election
she quit kind of midterm and she said
that's enough I'm feeling full I'm
feeling spent
Serena Williams I think you know quit
instead of going longer than she should
have she could after I think 27 years
and like that was enough she hit her
point that was enough
Cameron Diaz I suddenly after watching
There's Something About Mary with my kid
said I wonder whatever happened to her
and I looked up and saw that she was the
fifth highest grossing actress in
America the highest paid Hollywood
actress over 40 and then she'd had
enough and so she just quit to do other
things I should interview her yeah I
love those stories I mean she would
probably not say yes but I mean those
stories are fascinating yeah people are
just like yep goodbye about
personal challenge of making yourself do
something else
that most of us stay in the game for too
long so I really admired that Jacinda
Arden did that when politicians are
known for trying to hold on to power as
long as they can right until they're
forcibly removed and you know Kicking
and Screaming yeah I really admire that
she did that
I was super super influenced by Felix
Dennis's book called How to get rich
I just have to say it's definitely
not suitable for family listening but
the audiobook is exceptional I think
it's Roy McMillan who's the narrator and
I know that because I looked it up
because I was so impressed by the
narrator oh but just listen anyway I
just want to say how's it not suitable
does it well I mean look you have a very
particular
different orientation on these things
but most parents probably don't want to
listen to an audiobook that's like yeah
and then I spent all the money on coke
and Horrors okay that's what I thought
you were thinking yeah that is one
specific thing but that's so wonderful
that he admitted that it's funny for
that reason right because he's so candid
yeah in a way that you would not
normally find yeah in most books like
this Unapologetic on other things the
whole thing is refreshingly unusual yeah
I enjoyed it I love that book okay so I
interrupted them no it's great and I
read that at a key time it was right
about the time that we met like 2008 I
was just selling CD Baby
and
I was suddenly you know coming into more
money than I could ever spend in a
lifetime and just about that time I read
Felix Dennis's book how to get rich and
in it he had this quote that I I got
ready for our conversation here he said
if I had my time again knowing what I
know today I would dedicate myself to
making just enough to live comfortably
as quickly as I could by the time I was
35 I would then cash out and retire to
write poetry and plant trees
so I read that at a key fork in the road
moment for me where I just sold CD Baby
I had a ton of money it's like what to
do now and I read this book from this
Filthy Rich old man
being entirely honest and I thought I
should just learn from his experience
yeah and so I took his lesson to heart
and I said all right Felix Dennis said
if he could do it all again he would
just retire and write poetry in plant
trees and haven't planted any trees yet
but it's kind of what I'm doing so if
what I'm doing seems weird it's because
I took his advice to heart and I've
kind of quit the game so I think the
here's how we can summarize it is to say
that most people I think
go by the the inner compass that says
I'm really good at this game so I should
keep playing
but I think we should all entertain the
idea we could say I'm really good at
this game so I should stop playing